je voudrais pour une opa de faire
quelque chose de nouveau si cette femme
et armateurs elle possède deux
chalutiers
c'est dans cet esprit d'efficacité que
se sont déroulées pendant trois jours
les états généraux de la femme esprit
constructif rationnel avec le souci de
ne pas être considérés comme des
suffragettes et des féministes
nous avons choisi pour retracer
brièvement le travail des congressistes
trois commissions la première est celle
du couple il fut question de
l'information et de l'éducation sexuelle
de la contraception de l'avortement de
la réouverture des maisons closes et de
bien d'autres problèmes
nous avons abordé tous les problèmes du
couple du plaisir sexuel à la
responsabilité partagée
il faut que tous les problèmes
essentiels concernant la femme qui sont
discutées ou qui seront discutées à
l'assemblée ailleurs soit discutée en
tenant compte en priorité de l'opinion
des femmes la commission du travail du
fort à faire car c'est peut-être là que
les inégalités entre l'homme et la femme
est la plus essentielle
le travail est un élément important de
l'épanouissement de l'être humain
la notion de travail à travail égal
salaire égal
admise de tous devrait fait l'objet
d'une loi assorties de sanctions
vis-à-vis des employeurs et ceci est
très important pour nous de telle sorte
qu'elle est effectivement en application
la commission de la politique a été
beaucoup plus mouvementée à retenir la
phrase de l'une des congressistes à
propos de l'action sociale en haletant
quand on a la passion les moeurs de 8 1
voici quelques points importants de la
france
nous sommes tous tombés d'accord sur le
fait qu'il n'existe parti n'y ait pas de
parti séminaire d'autre part le travail
que nous avons élaboré ne sera pas tout
entièrement satisfait loi est là mais je
crois qui constituera une base de
travail très bonne pour l'avenir
nous sommes bien sûr très décidés à
participer de plus en plus à la vie
politique de la nation et il faudra
désormais tenir compte des 53 % de
l'électorat total que nous représentons
après toutes ces discussions
la notion d'efficacité a été posée
mademoiselle vous avez presque tout
vingt ans que vous êtes d'accord avec
tout cela général
nous sommes d'accord sur le fond mais ce
qui est plus important pour nous c'est
que sur la forme soit prise très vite
parce que comme on a 20 ans et pendant
dix ans que cela va réaliser sur tout